that's hilarious like pre-twitter early
twitter days you and jack dorsey
are in a room together talking about
javascript solving some kind of menial
problem terrible problems yeah i mean
not terrible just like boring boring
widget pro i think it was the audio
widget we were working on at the time
i'm surprised anyone paid me to be in
the room as an intern because i didn't
really provide any value i'm very
thankful
to anyone who included me back in the
day uh it was very helpful so thank you
for listening i mean is there uh
odia that's a precursor to twitter
first of all did you have any
anticipation that this jack dorsey guy
could be
also a head of a major social network
and um second did you learn anything
from the guy that like did
do do you think it's a coincidence that
you two were in the room together
and it's
the coincidence meaning like
why does the world play its game in a
certain way were these two founders of
social networks i don't know it's so
weird right like i i mean it's also
weird that
mark showed up
you know in our fraternity my sophomore
year and
we got to know each other then like long
before instagram it's
it's a small world but
let me tell a fun story about jack um
we're at odio and i don't know i think
ev was feeling like people weren't
working hard enough or something
nice and
i can't remember exactly what he he
created this thing where every friday
i don't know if it was every friday i
only remember this happening once
but he had us like a a statuette
it's like of mary and in the bottom it's
it's hollow right and
i remember on a friday he decided
decided he was going to let everyone
vote for who had worked the hardest that
week
we all voted closed ballot right we all
put in a bucket and he tallied the votes
and then whoever got the most votes as i
recall got the statuette
and in the statue it was a thousand
bucks whereas i recall there was a
thousand bucks now it might have been a
hundred bucks but let's call it a
thousand it's more exciting that one
felt like a thousand um it did to me for
sure i actually got two votes i was very
happy we were a small company but i as
the intern i got at least two votes so
everybody knew how many votes they got
individually yeah yeah i think it was
one of these self-accountability things
anyway i remember jack just getting like
the vast majority of votes from everyone
and i remember just thinking like
like i couldn't imagine he would become
what he'd become and do what he would do
but i had a profound respect that
the new guy
who i really liked
worked that hard and you could see his
dedication even then and that people
respected him
that's the one story that i remember of
him like working with him specifically
from that summer
you